[Applause]
so there are many things to consider to
be good at tekken from character
knowledge combos frames or even movement
like forward dash back dash or side
steps
but what really makes a player great is
their ability to perform when the game
is on the line
facing seemingly insurmountable odds
with everything hanging in the balance
they dig deep down and somehow find a
way to conquer those odds
oh [ __ ] that's not are you serious oh my
god kudos is crazy
my god hey my name is drew and welcome
to another ochoto tv special these are
the most clutch moments in tekken
tournaments
[Applause]
[Music]
he takes him to the rodeo what's gonna
happen next he is now at a huge life
advantage here oh boy oh he caught him
with a second in he could have killed
him there unbelievable the rodeo at the
end shows jdcr being a little bit
flustered here
and they're low on life but ayachi does
have breaks what a place wait a minute
who's sending who to the rodeo reverse
cowgirl
watch out
oh my god he's still alive i can't
believe it he got a little he's got the
race drive he's dead he's dead
oh my god it was a heartbreaking finish
jumping so
close to sending jdcr to losers
final round game two set point for poke
chop winner gets to the top if it's post
up david
we'll see how it goes the low kick
another one you know it on here we go
victor original now what's the
punishment
key block he's got the lead now what a
getup kick this is trouble
all
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god
talking great drive radio throw whip
that's both plays in range another one
oh my god
one more round
he's gonna do a ton of damage go for it
oh my god besides the help of your point
though
you can't knock out this man out jimmy
try and put him away the shoulder out of
nowhere get me with the side rolling
into the back position he's got the wall
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god
what is happening johnny down
what is happening people
my heart oh no
oh
oh my god
john ding
finishing the one two one for the two
hits he went for the two hits oh my god
oh my god what was that that was intense
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
damage oh ellen dammit what you can do
broken here though oh my god he cornered
himself again
oh my god
it's going to be big damage this is
going to be
going gonna be okay i'm getting harder
jack he's got a full beater he's gonna
die oh
my god
foreign
[Music]
is
thanks for watching and be sure to
subscribe too
[Music]
[Applause]
you